okay for people joining our livestream
this is the amazingly fourth consecutive
livestream meeting today this one is a
lost livestream meeting for the day not
my last meeting of the day by a long way
I should say but Tim this one is about
visualization so let's take a look
discrete plot so that's fairly
straightforward
it's an overhaul and does not work
before no there's an actual thing that
has to be do be done to support scaling
and labeling Oh Emmitt this is how long
this is oh I see the can I combine these
sure yeah okay yeah that should okay
fine so which plots don't yet have
support for these things it's I mean
scaling functions it's probably about
halfway through so we haven't yet done
real plot and plot 3d and so on plot 3d
is okay and so I think we've got most of
most of the ones where you have F of
some domain what about parametric plots
parametric flat not yet yeah that's
gonna have some extra issues right right
okay okay most folks fine all right
discrete plot 3d same story yeah do we
have call
some 3d we do but I don't have any
really good compelling examples I mean
it's it works but nothing that has
really looked great and Raven so that's
the list point plot 3d case which also
works right I understand so I'm going to
I'm going to say call out of hash coma
just been more exotic oh I love that
time sign okay so that's gonna make a
bunch of call-outs and then I'm going to
say list point plot 3d mm-hmm oh that's
really cool
right and we have that in eleven three
yeah I remember actually because we use
that for a feature space plot 3d exactly
yep right okay all right
plot markers so this is and you know
mainly fixing a whole bunch of bugs and
what we have now is that the plot
markers are going to better follow the
style of the curve that they're on and
we added some more named what is this
stuff here sighs you know default marker
how big it is as a very bizarre high
specification I don't think so does that
mean it's some number of pixels right
yep I think we should consider saying
something like um first of all we should
consider having pixels as a unit why
don't we do that
it might work what happens if we say um
seven pixels or something I agree with
you I don't think most people unless
they are very familiar with a graphics
language knows that offset is the way to
get pixels it's a totally obscure on
yeah it was probably from one oh yeah
yeah I mean we might also want to
Pepa that does this but I think that
this having seven pixels work would be a
good idea that so that's obviously in
the quantity object right but but
obviously will not work now or cassettes
that these no good graphics that's an
independent unit so that's not actually
a thing that plays nice with them yeah
you should we should talk to the
quantity object yet does it like points
printers points yeah I think it seems to
like that better desktop publishing I
don't know it does like you're better
but that's kind of the I see desktop
publishing points means so it's not
printers points which is 172nd of an
inch which is an absolute unit so to be
clear Stephen if you wanted a different
name just here for these functions that
would be easy if you want to change the
graphics language that's a more
substantial change right and I'm not
sure that those are different
I suspect that those are actually the
same there
unless pixels is you know one for you
know half of a publishing point on a
Retina screen or whatever sorry I I got
distracted for a second good you repeat
well I was trying to decide whether
pixels and points you know would be the
same thing or no it's a giant can of
worms display you know it's possible
that we should actually have you know
absolute display size blah blah blah
because we may have to annotate it in
all kinds of complicated ways or
actually displayed size analogous to
scaled so I'm saying so then then we
could give because I mean again there's
gonna be complicated things you know do
you account for the Retina display do
you account for the fact that it's a
projector that's projecting a hundred
foot wide image those kinds of things
right you get this sort of stupid thing
I mean this was the thing that we were
considering having units in the front
end like millions of years ago and we do
have said there is a unit system in the
front end I believe um do you know how
it works
[Music]
not convincingly listen I recommend that
we look at having something called
displayed size and that we reinvestigate
the unit system in the front end and
merging I mean there was a thing we
planned like 15 20 years ago to merge
the effective unit system that exists in
the front end with this and we never got
around to it um and I think maybe now is
the time I mean it'll take a while to
propagate that thing through the whole
system but um I think that's I like
the term displayed sighs which you know
a prett hmm you're taking notes right
yes I mean it's you know it goes along
with absolute point size and things but
you know displayed size is it might even
be absolute displayed size but I think
displayed size is reasonable and it goes
along with scaled and where exactly what
displayed size be used right there for
example it's a way of saying I mean this
offset thing is a crazy thing that
people don't understand particularly one
argument form of offset is really color
not so okay anyway that's my suggestion
there so here plot markers what is plot
markers doing is plot markers having a
first element of that list that is the
style and the second element is the size
or what yes so the automatic there means
use different shapes for different
curves or different set of points
you
yeah you know I have to say the concept
of having a wrapper that means display
this thing at a certain size it's like
inset isn't it I mean this is really
like saying inset this graphic with the
size might even actually be using inset
I don't know and in this case yes right
so insert oh I see that has a position
so really what we want is something I
mean better than this weird list thing
would be something that has yeah I mean
I don't think you want inside I think he
wants no you want something which is is
represents a thing you want something
that represents okay so this is a thing
that gives is a unit of is a is a unit
of size effectively mm-hmm and there
could be a quantity analog of that the
next thing you want is you know display
at size you know or sized thing comma
size so it's analogous to inset
position lesense set right i mean and
arguably you should be able to do things
like say in set of sized of whatever and
then that size would pick up the fourth
argument of inset right so sound around
live stream asks our plot might is
finally going to be replaced by graphics
primitives rather than inserting pieces
of text yes that was needed to they can
be off as you probably everybody who's
used them the first generation system
which used the typesetting is not
precise enough it's off by a pixel and
it creates discharging jarring plots
um sorry I'm just trying to put this
information in ILD hold on a second um
background noise by the way okay okay um
okay all right so listen I think these
are important directions these things
here displayed size and sized so can we
make sure we come back to those in are
you going to remember that Brett mm-hmm
okay all right let's keep going
yep oh that's a big improvement
indeed yeah okay
these are nice now I assume that that
one wants by default to change both the
color and the marker style yeah I guess
so I think so okay I don't know for some
reason these always look like so 1980s
these things with plot markers but
anyway absolutely how many points you
have yeah I'm not a big fan of I mean
just of that formalization but I I don't
think that the I think they've sort of
come back in style with information
visualization and dashboards and other
things people used in the lot yeah well
we're supporting a nice version of them
so let's be happy
yeah yep okay labeling oh cool okay okay
so there's you know some of these
I'll feature some of them are slightly
bigger features so then the current I
mean that's the new behavior and this is
probably the subtlest of the features is
that when we so for 3d labels when we
compute their position their automatic
position it's geared toward the initial
viewpoints so stuffs not jumping around
or trying to adjust as you rotate and
then 11 3 it was not taking perspective
into account and now it is magnificent
can I see the difference well you have
to bear but it's better so if you reset
that one back to its original viewpoint
right-click default view okay I believe
you
but it's actually an important point
that we should document for people that
the labeling is rendered at the time of
the initial in other words the viewpoint
if you interactively change viewpoint
you will not get the correct labeling
you think arguably there should be a
wave and then the right-click menu to
real able it if you understand what I'm
saying I understand what you're saying
I'm not sure how or easier heard that
would be okay just a suggestion I don't
think that's critical
Sanders exclamation marks appreciating
the fact the meshes in the same color um
okay he's asking about feature space
plot and how big the images are in the
feature space plot we do have a way of
controlling that don't we
labeling size okay is that documented
nicely in features place plot it should
be okay maybe you can check yeah okay
all right let's move on okay
so what this is gonna be subtle or
somewhat subtle okay so let's see which
was its which okay so the first one we
have so all 20 of these plots have the
same points the same labels yeah that's
a question of which labels get what get
actually rendered based on I think it
should be called label priority not
label wait maybe I think label weight
suggests what I thought you meant by
that was boldface versus whatever else I
see label priority is fine does it go
the right way around bigger numbers are
more priority bigger numbers are more
priority it can be infinite and well
basically that right in my or prayer
unfortunately is priority one tends to
mean the top priority right see weight
is the wrong thing because weight
suggests they'll all be rendered it's
something like priority or weight label
that's not ordering again weight in
terms of what's more important less
important has the same problem as
priority sometimes you it depends on
perspective and and unfortunately all of
them are used ranked No
qinger no because that has the same
problem again yes one is the top-ranked
importance yeah
precedence may be called preference that
preference
I will precedence yeah precedence
doesn't sound right
right
I think priority sounds okay you know we
just have to say you know what you know
higher numbers are more important
as opposed to lower numbers are more
important
yes Sandra livestreams
suggesting label preference value I
don't think it really helps anything um
yeah I did think about importance being
suggested on the live stream but Brian
um I think important system
yeah preference you didn't like right
we've got I don't know quite what
preference means I mean preference three
he doesn't really usually mean anything
whereas priority three does you know
that the notion that there is a
numerical priority makes some sense I
don't even remember in in like in UNIX
priorities like nice are larger numbers
larger numbers are lower right yes yes
by the way is it obvious that we've got
the numbering the right way around here
do we actually want higher numbers to be
more important I mean if you want to go
the other way I don't think you know it
shouldn't be a big major code change no
I understand but which is right I mean
all right to me it makes more sense to
say it's a more important label I don't
know you know importance is not
important suggests too much importance
to the whole thing right I mean I guess
I'm thinking of a lot of things where
you know like labeling planets or you
know stars or something where you're
going to have some property that
yeah like the massive more massive ones
should get a higher priority or
something yes there you just said it
higher priority
ha ha ha ha ha ok so that the term is
higher priority is bigger numbers which
does make some sense when you say it
that way I'll make a note of that okay
so does this work I mean this priority
mechanism yes which is oh this is doing
for I see so this is showing which why
isn't this making me see only the 20s
and things I mean so the bottom one
where you have the weights the 20 always
wins over everything else
that's one more we don't have the
weights was I not paying attention here
I'm sorry what is this doing ok so we
have a bunch of random points and point
one has weight one you can see that but
this is a trek cetera and so right now
if they aren't don't have any priorities
then it's sort of whichever one you
comes first right but so here why am I
not just seeing the patient matter
Stephen okay
location matters um right I mean so this
doesn't force a label to appear it
settles you know if if this point
collides with that point about Labor
languages what Sandra is asking about on
our live stream is can you force the
labels to appear which is what the next
section is okay and so we
two settings here I think we only need
one so right now we have which option is
this this is you know essentially these
are places within like placed or
labeling although we have syntactic
shortcuts for it which is labeling
function goes to true and labeling
function goes to or call it you know
true and and all true will allow labels
to overlap but it won't allow a label to
overlap a point okay and all anything
goes okay but but but why is this a
third argument to call out why is this
not an option I mean I understand
there's a local version of this which
which says what that particular label
should do but don't we also want a
global version that says oh I just want
all the labels yes and in that case you
would say labeling function goes to what
oh all are true we don't have that yet
do we
I think so we certainly have labeling
function no I understand but do we have
labeling function goes to all it should
I don't know that I've tested debts this
not recently okay well let's try it
why isn't that okay so let me just add
what but but it just made it a little
nervous there because it didn't work as
advertised okay
are you using external first of all yes
okay okay so hold on so that then this
here it was a branch problem there at
Bret don't you think there was something
there okay so labeling function arrow
wall okay good sign it's a good sign
that it's something different and but
okay that's interesting okay do labeling
function goes to above just for okay all
right didn't those numbers are very very
weird well okay so these are bugs but
but the point is here right the point is
that labeling function you know is the
global way of saying where do you want
something and I'm thinking of you know
the forced labeling is basically you
know so the automatic labeling is we
figure out what the position is and if
necessary we drop the label I understand
but why is a pause I read data exper and
position why is the third argument why
is position being true
positioning true as anything to do with
anything here that seems like a hack I
mean because you've got above below you
might want to say it's above and below
and I wanted to overlap that's I mean I
pretty sure that if you specify above
that it's going to put it above even if
it collides
well okay I'm open to other ideas so
this is saying where it is it's not
saying whether it appears
well I mean where it is is very general
but but not appearing at all
existentially where it is is is not the
best it seems to me maybe I mean and
generally in the case where it you know
gets dropped because it would have
Khalid's you know collided its place
becomes tooltip it's a very liberal
interpretation of place someone is
asking the lifestream what is the
difference between the label weights or
label priorities and ones without label
priorities good question what is the
difference between this and this between
which in which if and when there is no
label there is no weight there will have
uniform weight so what that means that
you can't have a preference you know you
can't put higher priority on something's
if there comes to a choice between two
labels sort of random which one gets
drawn no no I understand but it why am I
not seeing something whether it's much
more weighting towards bigger numbers in
the second case because my wage matters
location matters okay well so if I do
this for example I mean that won't
matter I mean because all that matters
is the ordering all that matters is the
ordering that obviously correct
shhh it's not obvious to me that that
would be the right optimization what did
you want instead what did I don't know
I'm thinking well I may not work because
whatever bug this is yeah I mean so what
happens is I mean the weights really
only matter when there would be
collisions right you know so if 19 and
20 are right next to each other and
would collide then only one of them can
win look by the way in terms of this
overwrite forced labeling I mean
basically label priority arrow infinity
or something like that I mean being able
to put label priority being able to say
um you know right there what is the you
get what I'm saying and
it seems to me it's a gradation it's a
continuous thing if you give it a
numerical priority right mm-hmm
then it will be sorted according to the
numerical priority but there are sort of
out of priority things like just always
display this I don't care where you know
what happens just always display it
where you think you should display it so
there's a there's a difference between
infinity right yeah and always display
it correct these are two separate axes
no I get it but I'm saying that this
this option label priority particularly
if it had different slightly different
name um would be I mean if it had a name
that was along the lines of label
forcing and then it's true or false or
true false or automatic you know okay
force this label so to speak right and
then it's it's if it's false it just
makes it into a tooltip if it's true it
forces the label and if it's a number
that defines a priority
I'll see you on our unify forest I want
to I want to unify for stern priority
because the think priority is a subtle
and minority thing because after all as
you say it's rather algorithm dependent
it's rather location dependent and it's
going to be somewhat obscure and that's
a case where you know I agree with you I
think that that would be the
consequences breath but I conceptually
in terms of this story for the user it
makes perfect sense I'm trying to think
real quick let's see
you
true/false in a number
well okay I mean it could work I mean
I'm thinking something like label
visibility or yeah I think that's good
you
that's a better name yet is a better
name visibility
yeah label visible label visible label
visibility visibility suggests there
might be a setting other than just true
or false no I think label visibility
seems reasonable yeah and it's
true/false or you know probably
automatic also is the default yeah
true/false automatic a number higher
number means people are complaining by
the way that our 3d feature space
feature space plot 3d is too slow give
any comments on that my experience is
that any slowness in the feature space
plots tends to be on the feature
extraction dimension reduce said
somebody is pointing to a feature space
plots somebody is pointing to her I
wonder if I've a Glee recall that there
was something that was missing that was
getting in later
- seriously speed up to mention reducing
those things there yes there is
I mean I think yeah I mean dimension
reduction and there's some new
algorithms for this t-sne algorithm and
so on um all right I like label
visibility true/false automatic or
combines these two things yep sounds
good and the people on the live stream
if you have a feature space example
feature space for example that you think
is slow I send it to support and I'm
sure it will get a live stream right now
and we'll make sure it actually goes to
the right person well I mean I'm not
sure how big the example is yes um okay
okay visualization functions supporting
labeling when do we get filling for
parametric plots or is it an undefined
concept that's an undefined concept
we've been down that route
what we've been down that road many
times it still doesn't stop me from
trying to figure out how to make it work
once a year or something isn't it really
the main issue isn't it the extraction
of the function to feed in a parametric
region would give you the the the region
that you could then do things with is
that correct Roger yes it yes so that's
really the right way to think about it
and maybe we should have some you know
in properties and relations or
parametric but it's a little bit
different okay when you say okay this
actually we're gonna have a big meeting
on polygon so you'll learn everything
about sort of how to define fills oh
okay it's it's a it's I mean it's it
takes a little bit of build up in the
end it's I'm just I'm sorry that I
something goes through my mind that that
unfortunate we don't have any developer
his name is Phil working in this area
otherwise this beautiful nominative
determinism of that feature right okay
onward please yeah um please go on yeah
I don't want to derail us cuz it will
take you know we're gonna hit it's a
little bit later
right okay we have an example from our
livestream which I agree is going to
fail
I'm not even gonna do this forum I'm
just going to say I mean what-what would
happen here so let's just try for
example random sample 200 or something
we're grinding we're grinding
well there's a horrible bug but yeah
it's living under while frozen the
stream the that's software we work on
daily test interesting features every
day right you have the soup that is the
algorithm what is the you map algorithm
do we know what the you map algorithm is
it's not an algorithm for the the
feature space layout or is that an
algorithm for rendering okay this
requires investigation can we feed whose
I'll take a look at it and feed it to I
mean yes Andrea is having so if you can
feed this you map thing to to attend and
Matteo and my damn horse attend machine
learning folks okay so we just saw this
before right you showed me the supply
grains is to call out right so but for
some reason this isn't working here I
don't recommend string not sure why that
whatever doesn't but it now works
basically okay let's keep going
okay stream plot oh wow
lot of exciting stuff here guys all
right what what what should I see with
Geo stream plot doesn't that require
this geo vector thing that yes it
greatly benefits from geo vector so I
don't think have I reviewed geo vector
yet I don't think so
no not yet should we put the geo stuff
in a separate meeting because we're not
we're gonna run out of time here and
we're gonna I think the Geo stuff should
be reviewed with Jose okay um we'll add
it to the geo to Jose's geo stuff it
doesn't matter Steven this can be
covered here because it it's in terms of
making the quality that we want from
these plots having do vector was you
know and a or the corresponding
computation was very important it's not
really user visible that much okay but I
understand that but where do I see and I
just have reference page you know
prototype reference pages I mean open
source yeah
okay I mean I just wonder what's
happening I don't understand like for
example if I have wind vectors which
have a certain you know such and such a
number of miles per hour or something
are you handling units and things in
appropriate ways
mm-hm well look at that wind vector data
what do you know except those are random
reels those aren't quantity objects I
mean those are positions I mean that's
just randomly sampling wind over there I
see I see I see I see I see I see wind
vector data is in miles put so if I say
I'd forgotten even had this if I'd said
if I say for example wind vector data of
here which probably isn't actually where
you get a pair of miles per hours or
misses why not I can look out the window
here and see what I see here um what
does the miners
mean well it's measured you know Eastern
North or something right so that means
that it's going west and south or
something I don't remember exactly which
way when director data is coming out
I hope it's consistent that's something
can we can we make a note andraia when
we get to the geo review can we make
sure we make make sure that that's all
correct and consistent but okay this is
magnificent okay so this is that's
actually very nice okay
and the main point is that that's a Geo
position I see coordinates and vectors
and that's the way stream plot works as
well right right how do you how do you
normalize the lengths here and fees are
in quantities that you just it's just
relative normalization right so what
happens is you know for the vectors what
you want to do is you want to do the
appropriate rotation under whatever map
projection and then make sure that you
know if vector a was twice as long
before that it's still twice as long
we're gonna have to talk about this in
geo meeting yep that's that's um okay
let's come to multi-panel plots a very
exciting thing so it's a limited release
now Steven look in that garbage here is
this y is the magnification oh that's a
bug isn't it yeah I'll take a look at
that what's a payoff but I want to say
Steven it's it's limited you know it's
the graphics grid
you see I'm saying it says next release
cuz there's a lot of more conforming
that needs to happen for that but it's
supported in a number of sort of the
list line related things like date list
plot and things like that
why is it putting these labels and all
these totally weird places so that's a
way to optimize when you have a grid to
not have too many labels so you don't
since they of shared x-axis let's say
that the things that are above and below
you don't need to put it everywhere and
that's how you typically do compact
arrays but I mean you'd want to put it
in a consistent place no it's only
bizarre and well that's because it's
just an arbitrary you know it doesn't
fit the grid very well it it if you have
a 3x3 grid of plots this looks very nice
okay can I run that I should be able
you
you
oops I just want to say what do I say I
just column no that's the single column
so now I say column comma three look at
that so what otherwise would happen
Steve why is the more gutter space but
needs notice that this morning M that's
about it but look here at the bottom see
them okay
the labels they would clash into each
other otherwise yeah okay so this is an
example of of getting the same
information but not overdoing it so you
can have more effective plots I think
this should be suitable how this well it
should be I don't have a way hooked in
through this line plot yet I need to I
find it really weird to put the simplest
line plot this capability I think that I
think that that's actually going to be a
way that many people get to it okay and
the other advantage in when you're in a
domain like that you do know that you
have sort of shared X and y axis
yeah I realize that whereas otherwise
you don't have any idea what right
everything's you know hodgepodge and you
can't make any well I mean you can make
assumptions that the user coordinates
agree so to speak within these plots you
can assume that the user coordinates are
aligned yeah
yes so and this is certainly you know by
the way I'm sorry the automatic plot
setting here if this top row had much
bigger values than the bottom rows you
get what I'm saying so you can share
on a per row basis I'm saying how
because you not sure if we want to go
down that routes and what happens with
the aspect ratios I mean do the aspect
ratios and all the panel elements have
to be the same right now yes I think
they should you know graphics grid is a
different story but I think they should
I mean and so like if you add aspect
ratio goes to one on your list line
plots so this is an improvement right
there I mean the fact that those axes
line up is very good that's that's what
you did right yes yes yeah that's
terrible
this is this is a major improvement
that's super more useful that's great
yeah I mean that's a silent change
because nobody's gonna want this
behavior this behavior is just dopey
right well presumably yeah I think it's
dopey but but there are more cases to
sort out for graphics grid before we can
sort of say that we I think we'll get a
little bit of graphics great improvement
along the lines of what you see there
well right I mean this is okay so and I
assume graphics row and graphics column
and so on are that they're all the same
okay all right so let's come back to
your functionality here I mean so for 12
what I think we should do for like this
line plot or whatever is that you know
for the most part options are shared
across all the panels
I mean because the idea of
I agree I agree with you and plot layout
is the right place to put this I agree
with that too yeah all right okay and
this makes sense so it's not the full
rollout that we want but I think it's
still quite used and you need to fix
this whatever this magnification
screw-up is here yeah I'll take a look
at that so does it work for plot as well
the plan is to support this plotless
line plot the log variants dateless plot
date list log log plot bar chart but not
plots not on the initial list okay I
don't think it's as important as these I
mean I think we're always gonna need it
in the end um what's the a log of these
things in 3d I mean because you can
imagine a totally bizarre thing where
you have an imp an old plot and as you
rotate it they all rotate together yes
and I'm not really thinking about those
cases at all yet you know other than 3d
you know here be dragons okay but but
that the thing I just mentioned will be
a really really nice feature to be able
to rotate together I think you know so
yeah we've thought about that but so we
there's as many more things to think
about there and there's more 2d stuff to
be done
- um someone's asking her can you try
adding some frame axes labels good
question what happens if you do that so
what happens to frame labels what
happens if I want to label these
separate plots so what happens if I want
to do plot label for each of these
separate plots so go ahead and put
let's see turn that random rail into an
association with well what about what
did I just say plot label here okay yeah
plot labels goes to random word of three
Oh lay bolts yeah so usually we get plot
when did we get plot labels plural a
while ago what does it do associate that
label with each curve with each data set
oh yeah yeah right I see that's nice so
it's extending the frame a little bit
and moving the label inside and then you
can still have an overall outer plot
late yeah I get it I get it that's nice
okay so then let me understand okay so
what about if I have axes labels I don't
think I'm doing anything with axes
labels yet shouldn't be hard to hook up
although axis labels strictly speaking
won't do anything here because those are
frames
okay so there's one at the bottom and
while there's also one the left which is
interesting love to take a look at that
okay so I think there's still some work
to do with that especially if there's I
mean what how would you specify
different
well the argument would be how would you
specify different frame labels I mean
right I mean the argument is that there
aren't different frame labels that's you
know in this plots you still only have
four sides yeah I understand what about
people who want different axes on the
two sides correspond with different with
curves corresponding to the two
different axes so that's next this
future okay all right more complications
this is this is an important case here
right so there's one other change we
made to several of the functions let's
plot plots etc I don't know if we
included them on the list here I'd like
to play around with this a little bit
more but what once it's really supposed
to be you know in shape yep um for
example the gap if I do something you
know this fill
what I did why did that do column comma
for why did that not work and why didn't
that work well seems wrong yeah it's not
hurt good is it three or anything well
that worked but for did not us five dear
let's find out it's number theoretic
somehow well I think for didn't like the
orphan
you understand there's gonna be a single
orphan I mean it that shouldn't I mean
there's a single orphan there no there
isn't
well there isn't in the Andros but there
wasn't a there wasn't a row wise orphan
here I think it doesn't like the row
wise orphan possibly and arguably it's
not completely obvious what the row wise
orphan should do should it go to the
left I suppose so yeah I'd like to with
these why don't you try and finish this
off and let's try and get meeting that
involves Jeremy or somebody from design
to just look at these one time okay but
that's very beautiful
alright let's suppose the I mean before
we get to the uncertainty the other
thing that we've been changing is for
several of the plots we've set axes and
frame to automatic by defaults
so right now you often have the problem
if you put on frame you also also turn
off axes I see okay and it's really kind
of annoying there's a lot of ugly things
you might want that so you can still do
it but what you did what you did
automatic behavior be if you switch on
framed yeah well but the axis could be
in the middle of the page right but but
often you don't want it well we can't
change that behavior whatever we've had
going for the last 25 years we should
keep going with please don't change that
that will break a lot of stuff okay okay
it's it's it's okay we can turn it back
on and then it just means two people
have to continue setting two options I
think we should do that for now you can
you can raise that with me again
okay we're do we don't have time to
solve this okay um
questions from our live stream that are
interesting by the way somebody's
pointing out the multi column
um has the same bug apparently
and five gives totally weird yeah what
the heck I think I might actually be
using multi-column no I'm using well
whatever whatever it is I'm just parts
of shoulder fine up to four give up to
400 up to four right which is what it
allows yeah that's fine the dangling
humph okay well Chester bug please let's
get that reported who's who's the keeper
of multi-column Lu okay
I'll report it okay next question here
can we have one more than one data set
per plot and that's now okay what do we
think the syntax is going to be for that
we don't know not sure yet let's talk
about that for a second so we don't cut
ourselves off I mean
suits affair it's effectively a style of
grouping things
right I mean so I think the two main
possibilities are either a set of set of
data sets yeah or something already or
not not really I mean it's certainly not
documented okay slot layout that that
specifies how things are grouped
together right you know so some way of
saying you're one and two are together
and three and four are together and five
six and seven are together okay let's
see um yeah all right so that so that's
the thing to still be figuring out well
can't get everything in this particular
release this is already very nice thing
and I really really really like the
improvement to graphics grid we have a
question on our live stream nice feature
is moved from a static graph to dynamic
ones you can rotate 3d godbut scale
numbers don't dynamically adapt display
resolution when you're in larger plot so
nice - what do you mean scale numbers
don't automatically nice to put a zoom
and drag tools so it adds additional
arrows when zoomed in oh I see what
you're saying so yeah I mean the point
is that in the current way we're doing
things so with the exception I mean to
give an example of technology which
hopefully will be added to many things
soon but if you do dynamic Geographics
right this is an example of I don't know
let's try you know excited for example
why is this taking for a little load I
don't know
there we go so the question is wow it
lost some tiles in New Jersey um as I
said they're not affected by the
hurricane so fortunately okay but I mean
the question is this type of
functionality for plots has long been
discussed I have to say that it keeps on
not being as important as one thinks it
is going to be I mean for something like
living that we're talking about and
there's also sort of post 12:12 one
probably to sort of finalize dynamic
image and possibly get a dynamic
graphics at that same time that will be
great I mean of course the other thing
we really need is the it's some kind of
drawing tools thing like the image tools
here and we have this intern who's
supposed to start soon who's going to
try and do a redesign of the graphics
tools stuff drawing tools stuff um okay
Lucy made me work
uh his name is Noah Noah Hardwick I
think um and I think it's a gonna end up
being with Jeremy okay we could point to
meet you too
so summer school chapter um
okay let's look at uncertainty plots
very exciting in on those birds result
lines are showing up higher okay so the
basic point here is this is so the
default error bar function is just the
bars so the default is the bars with the
small cross hatches most cross hatches
what are those bars near the lines at
the top and the bottom serifs
what are they cool does the different
names hinges hinges is what you have
fences is box whisker charts and I
forget what the most recent thing I saw
for error bars was okay so what does
okay so so what are we calling this what
are we calling this case since that's
called ban bars what's this one called
that is can you open the ducky tools
notebook for error bar function
fences I don't know some kind of Western
motif that um no no it just would be
nice to have um I mean it's it's like
endcaps of some kind
end caps huh you don't expect a cap to
be flat unless it's a mortar board I
don't think we should call it mortar
boards no I don't think so either
why is it called fences anyway because
it sort of encloses the I actually
predict that's not the reason I predict
that's because of some typesetters
convention they're things called fences
and typesetting I mean an inn like led
type typesetting
maybe I believe that those are what term
absolute value signs are called for um
that used to be these names that
required no understanding of what the
what the things meant that were used for
led type typesetting type stuff okay why
is it called band as opposed to filling
or filled there called error bands and
typically when you have a curve yeah I
understand when you have a curb but what
what I think filled would be a better
term here although I mean if you look at
the case that has
said it is a curved thing I understand
okay fair enough
the other complaint I have is plural
versus singulars here ellipse or
ellipses right is it point no it's
policy it's a single ellipse oh my
goodness say okay so that that that
prejudice is the question of what kind
of fence it is right how can it be call
bars there should be bar then yes no but
that that doesn't make sense either
because it's bar oh boy we can do all
plural or all singular if well I think
we should just think about these names
well let's let's have a little look at
what else you've got here and let's go
back to these names the first question
is the very thing error bar function I
mean we've got three words running
around one of them is around one of them
is uncertainty and one of them is error
now I agree that these are roy's called
error bars not uncertainty bars or
anything right the other thing is we
will have other things than around that
you want to visualize s as error bars
sure I'm saying okay fair enough
but in that case if you say Arabah you
cannot have a thing called bars here
that has got to be none look if this
basically says these are really the ends
of the curves mostly huh well I know the
thing that occurs to me just now looking
at that table is oh actually I guess
it's in the table above is that you know
there's also none which is yes I know
you have uncertainty I don't care
yeah I understand so that's not going to
work for this okay so
I'm thinking and this is not very good
flat ends point ends
I don't think end is the right word um
but those three let's look in the
literature
let's ask Jose whether there are some
other names for these okay um
I don't really know ends is a horrible
horrible construct open/closed it's an
interesting idea I don't think that
necessarily I mean that's kind of like
an is that really a closed interval
looking thing a where I don't know which
one is closed here well I mean I would
be happy getting rid of points if it's
you know was the odd man out in terms of
naming no I wouldn't I know we want that
I mean that's useful okay um
somebody's suggesting limit bars yeah
because these are at the limits well of
some kind of limit I mean out really at
the limits they're at the 1 Sigma point
maybe or something mm-hmm what depends
on what the yeah thing is if it's an
interval then you know that these are
coming from then you know it really is a
limit yeah
I mean do we really want to call it
error bar function as opposed to you
know interval display function or
something I'm not super happy with error
bar because here's the basic point is
that we're gonna have to systematically
work through most of our of these
functions and figure out how to
visualize uncertainty it's gonna take a
while and so yes many of them will not
be bars right correctly you know and so
one thing that you see is that it always
adds sort of a dimension to it
so in the case you start with a zero
dimensional entity like a point becomes
a line entity yes it comes a
one-dimensional thing you start with a
curve you create this strip or disband
and it becomes one few or tube in 3d you
might dimension it up all the way to a
tube okay okay so but that's that that
phenomena happens everywhere you know
whatever dimension well like our display
function or uncertainty display function
if we think it's always uncertainty
oh right I want something that sort of
it's not necessarily coupled to
uncertainty like well the question is
how close we get to uncertainty um
extended display function those are
totally obscure someone is suggesting
error markers there's not terrible if
we're gonna go for error that's probably
better than is it yes it's probably
better it's more analogous to plot
markers and that would allow us if we
wanted to to do something like interval
markers although I don't really like
that very much I think we should say
this is primarily for around what else
do you have in mind that this might be
for Roger because I think we're planning
lots of things ok so one thing that you
have is that let's say if you have a
model it has uncertain it has parameters
in it you want to compute what comes out
what variation comes out it might be it
it might be sort of they're all related
in some sense but they don't have that
strict statistical interpretation that
around has which is just one no she'll
let me give you another case in how do
you deal with time line plot when you
have an interval and time line plot
what what what option governs the way
the interval was rendered timeline plots
I mean I don't think there is an option
for that I mean think it just always
draws as you know from start to end okay
but so that's a case though which is an
analogous situation yeah so I mean you
know the indicators of those things for
example I could imagine actually that's
an interesting point I mean the open and
closed intervals business for time line
plots I can imagine since you have these
very beautiful open you know dots you
could close those dots mm-hmm but okay
so look there's an interval there
there's an interval but what are you
doing when there's a uncertainty in both
the X and y coordinates
you've gotta cross them across or that's
where the ellipse comes in okay okay
let's do one more round on this with
Jose because he knows the literature on
what some okay and I think all the
things I've seen so far I sort of like
interval Merkers it's not terrible I
mean I mean it's certainly much more
generic and not imposing a view on the
world sort of thing yeah I mean it would
allow us to if in the future we actually
allowed intervals in list plot which we
could couldn't we um I think it's in
there really well how does it display
same way
what with error bars mm-hm
that's pretty weird I mean because it's
default should not be the same a it may
have a different default it may not have
the cross things that the fences I don't
remember
switch that has done that or not okay so
this is fenced
yeah well that's very nice and that
again argues for some kind of interval
markers but don't fence it I mean in
fact those intervals shouldn't have up
to point in the middle either getting
rid of the point is harder well that is
sort of the point so dis yes not it
should be gotten rid of it maybe maybe
it will be a bug for this version yep
and that probably could be controlled
from interval markers as well whether
there is a point there or not right yes
okay fair enough
let let's just have a quick preview of
this cuz this is exciting yeah
magnificent we've wanted this for
millions of years thirty years actually
I mean we'd had versions this obviously
for all that time
ha okay very nice
you
yeah that's beautiful
beautiful so these are gonna be in there
for 12 mm-hmm as experimental or what I
don't think they need to be experimental
yeah I think they're fine
okay well I want to talk a little bit
about the color maps for this yes you
might want to open the next section
because that's gonna be all collar maps
actually the
the pages let's go to the ref ref pages
that's that's why it's not many more
things in here I would have expected
complex plots to be something different
I mean I am open to you know renaming
things and I also I would also bring up
Stephen complex plot 3d at the same time
okay this is great I didn't know this
was coming I mean I've been wanting this
for like millions of years but scroll
down to examples maybe well that's
magnificent okay so so one feature of
complex plots that I think you need to
see is the ability to
yeah and - and I want to see more of
these color maps so basically we're
introducing him but a 2d color map okay
so most a default most most what most oh
one privative families yes
so reintroducing a two parameter family
or two plum to families in of way it's
not it's somewhat factored it is for its
height that's just the right and this is
a kind of weird object which i think is
yeah we're still working on the legends
i'm pretty sure it's gonna go to a
button or a normal bar legend
it goes from - I don't know it's cool to
have it be circular like that the circle
is cool but it just takes up so much
space and make it smaller what do you
mean you have other reasons that's
suspicious well coming back to the - you
know so when you have you know something
that's effect you know affected by the
height as well well I think you should
do this circle I think I think it's
really nice to show the you know
circularity of the thing um but let's
talk about okay so complex list plot
versus complex plot see that's so weird
that it or no it no actually it isn't
weird it's the it's the same thing I'm
confused
I see what you're saying so that I see
it's like contour plot or something it
makes a well it isn't no no that that's
complex numbers and I know I'm putting
them in the complex plane right and
complex plot 3d it's just kind of weird
because it's the you know the absolute
value is being plotted so you have four
dimensions right it's four dimensions
that you need to cover one way or
another
plotting so I'm plotting as a function
of a complex number
I'm okay so what happens if I just want
to plot ABS as a function of the complex
number so if I if I do this and I simply
say okay so let's just just try this if
I say complex plot of ABS of cosine of Z
it'll be constant why because the color
is based on the argument that doesn't
make sense I mean what should happen
here in my view in this case is that the
ABS is somehow the you know the gray
level and the color the tint of the
thing is the Arg that what I would
expect that's that's what we have that
too okay if you scroll down and complex
plot two examples
where are those except here's okay yeah
so do that one but knock out the argh
part of it
so just record abs what the hell what
Swaggart I guided came up with this key
there are multiple such schemes yes I
don't think we should I mean I think we
should genera size that yes yes yes no
no no no we have okay these are old
example it's just the code isn't caught
up with the docs okay so what you have
here is that's very nice that's very
nice what whatever you have here is very
nice because this if I were to put an
ABS in there this would just do the
right thing right it would be constant
and shaded yeah yeah which is perfectly
reasonable I mean I would pick the
default color in this case to be not
quite as as devilish as this so to speak
those I
pick the default color map to be such
that that's a much more muted color that
makes sense now
what's that I mean so what happens is
you know in this case I mean you were
still visualizing the absolute alright I
realized that I realized that and the
odd happens to be zero and I'm saying
you should rotate your color rainbow so
that zero is not such a bright color
probably
zero to be a distinguished color but not
necessarily this color right if it was
the yellow for example this would look a
lot better this is a graphic designers
here let's get these those guys but this
is beautiful what this does is the right
default in my opinion definitively the
right default or something like this so
it's the top one or the bottom one of
the which of these two right I mean so
talk to you what the rainbow shape the
other thing colored by yeah I want I
want Lee I want the gray level to be the
the ABS and the hue to be and it's
basically like you know hue saturation
brightness so know the huge should be
the the argh now okay so there's there's
three parameters here right and the good
news is I mean the good news is that
color space is three-dimensional and I'm
suggesting using a parametrization where
the ABS determines the brightness that's
that's what we have it's actually values
its HSV it's not HSB but okay fine
saintil HSV so so then what you're
saying is the the direction know that
that's you only need two parameters
right because you need a section of the
ass but the point is to make it
perceptually you know those three
parameters in that column although you
can't perceive necessarily know I
understand I think this is very
successful I think that picture is
really good the other thing to keep in
mind here is that that you know light to
dark shading is being done cyclically on
sort of a log scale oh oh oh that's not
good yeah no I mean it is good we had
one that isn't but it's it's we have
examples of that we have that you can
pick that but it's not a successful all
right
another meeting which involves graphic
design folk for this thing sure but this
is wonderful
these are really cool pictures also
doesn't Michael trout have lots of
experience with complex plotting a
little bit weird I mean a lot of
especially with the Riemann surfaces
it's it's a little bit weird Steven I
mean they're sort of exhaustive in some
weird way well here just let's get him
in the mate next meeting we have about
this if we could um okay well so look I
I mean I could cancel this meeting that
I have right now but I would prefer to
do it
and come back to this one by a figure
that we would need one more session
anyway just fine yep fine there's some
wonderful stuff here well done
I mean it's some I'm really glad we got
these complex plots that's very very
nice that although clearly more thought
is required here um okay well great and
thank you to folks on the livestream
this was all right we are at the end of
our marathon for back-to-back designers
use that a live streamed and I just get
to go off and do other kinds of meetings
of no public interest here um there's
gonna say you're not live-streaming
until 3:00 a.m. I could write okay
great stuff to be continued okay thanks
oh okay
bye bye